Thought it would be nice to start off this talk with another talk.
Um,
this is Muriel Cooper head age 68 and she was,
this is the years 1994.
Um,
she's on stage at the fifth annual technology entertainment and design
conference held in Monterey,
California.
It's,
this is a ted talk.
It doesn't quite look like a Ted talk cause you notice she doesn't have on
choose to start with.
Um,
and she's made herself comfortable in the chair,
uh,
during this,
at this talk.
Um,
she was presenting the work of her students in the visible language workshop on
immersive interactive computer interface environments.
Uh,
the,
the talk was exceedingly successful,
so much so that apparently Michael,
Bill Gates asked for a copy of the materials afterwards.
It made a big impact in the world of graphic design where I was at the time I
was working out at Ideo in San Francisco and as an interaction designer when
that was a pretty new discipline,
I worked for one of our students and this work was absolutely everywhere in the
intervening years.
I was shocked to see it kind of received from view.
Um,
I think I'll play a little bit of this a video first.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
I have a couple of Chris'
philosophy.
First of all,
I'm testing the boundaries to see how truly comfortable when can make oneself
here.
And this is another portrait of Muriel Cooper.
This is from 1972.
Um,
this is,
uh,
well it's included in the book and it is captioned in the book as Muriel Cooper
in 1972 at MIT surrounded by unidentified males.
Um,
you see,
again,
she happens to not have on shoes.
Um,
but it's,
it should be clear that this work was done and overwhelmingly male context at
the Massachusetts Institute of Technology where of course,
um,
she had,
uh,
she,
she had a difficult time,
uh,
navigating among the,
hurdles that were thrown down in front of her,
but she did it with a great skill and aplomb according to those who are around
her.
So,
uh,
I think there's a nice image,
the combination of her sweater and the situation,
the dynamics going on in this image.
Okay.
This is a third portrait.
This is a self portrait of Muriel Cooper.
She's the one on the right in the image.
This was made in 1967 and this was made in the context of a computer aided
design and programming class that Muriel Cooper had a audited at MIT in the
department of mechanical engineering.
This class was taught by Nicholas Negroponte who went on to found the media lab
at Mit.
Um,
this image is made by a computer program as you might guess,
and in fact it's using an alphanumeric printer kind of against itself to turn a
new image making machine.
And we're,
we're well familiar with Ascii art at this point in 1967 considerably less so.
But there's something,
there are a number of qualities about this image,
which I think are typical of why her work is important.
One of which is,
uh,
she had a tendency to kind of use the existing and future looking,
tools against themselves to find out where the edges are and what,
where,
where it breaks,
what works,
what are the possibilities that haven't been outlined yet.
Um,
the second thing is she's,
she's pictured here together with her good friend Donna,
say Dondis who is also graphic design educator in Boston and a friend,
she studied together with the Mass College of art.
Um,
in many of the images that I may show you,
either Muriel Cooper won't be in them or else she'll be surrounded by other
people.
And I think this is one,
perhaps one reason why her work has relatively disappeared since 1994.
Um,
she,
it doesn't file itself neatly under the kind of a name of a single great author.
In fact,
it's,
it's largely collaborative.
The big,
the purple book is called Muriel Cooper,
but so much of the work inside is not directly her work in whether it's the work
of our students.
It's work that she facilitated by setting up situations and it's work which
jumped over disciplinary boundaries.
So it was kind of hard to file.
Um,
Muriel Cooper worked at Mit,
uh,
for 40 years.
She worked in,
uh,
well it's,
it's easy enough to break down her work into three categories.
Uh,
she first worked in design at MIT,
at the office of publications and then it's the first design director of the MIT
press.
So it was actually design and media director.
Um,
she taught in the school of architecture beginning in 1974,
uh,
instigating a class called messages and means and carrying on establishing the
visible language workshop,
which is a printing and teaching and design workshop.
Uh,
thirdly in 1985,
she was a founding faculty member of the Mit Media Lab,
uh,
found originated by Nicholas Negroponte.
She was one of several of the faculty who organize this facility.
And at that point she was working on computer interfaces.
Now I think if you probably asked her to think about those three words,
I think it would look something much more like this.
Um,
kind of all one activity.
They were never a discreet,
and in fact,
when she was working on books it,
the MIT press,
she was thinking about how they might appear on screen or when she was,
uh,
making a film of a book that I'll show later.
Uh,
she was thinking about how she might show that students and so there's this kind
of re overlapping and a recursive feedback loop between these activities.
However,
for ease of communicating the story,
we're going to leave it in it's three parts,
so I'll start in design.
In 1962,
the technology press,
which was MIT,
is in house publishing.
I was switching their name to the MIT press and the director of the press
consulted with Paul Rand,
a well known American graphic designer at the time and asked uh,
if he might consider doing their logo.
He said maybe he can't do it,
but he could recommend some people.
He recommend Muriel Cooper to do it.
Okay.
This is not the logo for the MIT press that Muriel Cooper designed.
This one is also not the logo for MIT press that Muriel Cooper designed.
Also not a logo for MIT press.
These were all proposals that Muriel Cooper made.
She was working as a freelance designer on this assignment.
Another,
I think this could have been a great logo for MIT press,
but it was not the one that she designed.
Finally,
this one's getting a bit closer to what eventually became one of her best known
works.
And in fact,
when I started digging through what exists in the Muriel Cooper Archive at
Massachusetts College of Art,
which is a bunch of bankers boxes with mixed materials in there,
inside of one I found among Reebok high tops and VHS tapes and sheets of slides,
I found that kind of crumpled up piece of a sketch paper.
And on that paper I recognize down at the bottom,
uh,
what would become the MIT press logo that's existed for 50 years by this point,
which would indicate some something about it success.
You see the lines here are the set of books drawn acts and symmetrically on a
shelf with the fifth one pulled up in the sixth one,
pulled down a,
here's the final version of that.
Uh,
if you kind of squint your eyes or raise your,
raise your bar for abstraction,
you'll see MITP,
which I'm sure we all see.
Um,
I think this is one of my favorite pieces of graphic design period.
Uh,
for a number of reasons.
One of which is,
um,
is I,
I suppose,
uh,
the fact that it has existed for 50 years,
um,
is a qualifier.
But I like the fact that it looks,
it's a static graphic,
but it looks like it's machine readable.
It looks like this is meant to be a barcode.
And something about that kind of equation in 19,
uh,
64 by this point,
that equation of books and publishing with electronic information and machine
readability,
I think that's a super strong insight and typical of why I think our work's
important.
Okay.
By 1967,
she became the first design and media director of the MIT press at the MIT
press.
She was overseeing a,
a ambitious publishing program that involved books like this book,
which is a,
um,
a collection of the papers delivered at a technical conference or this book,
which is by Seymour Papert and Marvin Minsky,
also cofounders of the media lab.
Um,
a book about computational geometry,
um,
or this book,
which is written by Nicholas Negroponte called the architecture machine,
um,
which was around early attempts to apply,
computers and software to architectural design.
Um,
there is a,
uh,
it was an ambitious and important publishing program that she was dealing with.
A,
this is another book that she designed while at MIT press.
This is called Bauhaus Weimar desalle Berlin.
Chicago was published in 1969.
It's a big book.
As meg mentioned,
it's the same size as the purple thing on the table over there.
It's about 14 inches tall.
I'm hardback book.
It was originally published in German and translated into English.
Um,
this book was of special importance to Muriel Cooper,
um,
the bow house,
a important design school in Germany and transferring to the United States,
uh,
that mixed hands on production and uh,
teaching and design and kind of overlapping ways.
It was a,
she considered that her,
uh,
principal point of departure for her teaching and her designing and her work.
She spent two years working designing this book.
The book included,
I'm Scilla by and correspondence and documentation of this essential,
um,
design school that originated around the industrial revolution.
And um,
this is the first edition was popular,
a second edition,
a slightly smaller paper back here.
She used the offset printing process,
which uses Cyan,
Magenta and yellow,
uh,
in overlapping,
over printing forms to um,
to produce all the,
a four color full color images here.
She just shifts the printing plates.
And what you're left with is a distinctive graphic that's a index of the process
or register or the process that made it.
And I think this is typical in our work as well.
And something else that certainly drew me to it.
Um,
it,
it's as focused on the process as it is on the product,
but not as an end,
not in order to get a strange or different product,
but more as a kind of equivalency between these things.
Um,
the Bauhaus,
the Bauhaus was no a distraction to Muriel Cooper at this time.
And Cambridge,
um,
Lazlo Moholy knowledge who was at the Bauhaus had come to Chicago to set up the
new Bauhaus,
which became the Illinois Institute of Technology Institute of design.
He brought with them the Yorkie Kapish who went on to head the,
um,
school in Chicago and then came to MIT and kapish brought Muriel Cooper into
work originally at the office of publications.
So this is a direct lineage there as well.
Walter Gropius who is running the bow house.
Previously it was down Massachusetts Avenue running the Graduate School of
design at Harvard.
So this was a,
there was a direct connection.
It was not looking from a distance when this book was done two years lavished of
time on it.
Um,
the MIT press did something that was kind of a surprising,
they launched a publicity campaign,
um,
to announce and promote this important book.
And for that,
for example,
they designed a letterhead.
I mean you're all Cooper designed to letterhead.
Uh,
they also designed posters.
This is like a 36 inch poster,
giant blowup with that self portrait of Moholy nudge.
But where the halftone screen is exaggerated to call attention to the kind of
mode of production that,
uh,
that this is using.
And it's strange to imagine that you might design and publish a poster to sell
books.
Um,
I'm not sure how many books it sold,
but this is the kind of a play that was going on I think often within Cooper's
work.
It's a second poster she designed same size.
Uh,
this includes every,
every spread in the book,
but this was done analog.
So each one of those is a piece of film and reduced to fit on this,
on this large format here we see a kind of detail and I expect what she was
hoping to get to from this was to imagine what it would be like to kind of
simultaneously understand this book,
um,
to see the images that are kind of a more exaggerated speed than what we're used
to at this moment.
It's a way to kind of interrogate,
to prod the media.
Um,
when she finished the book,
she did something else.
She made a film of the book where she spent,
uh,
three frames for every spread in the book,
made a 16 millimeter film,
which I'm going to let play right here.
This is a recreation of the film that was made for the exhibition that meg
mentioned at Columbia,
organized by Robert Watson Burger and myself.
Um,
what you see here is the material of the book flowing through the page grid or
kind of template of that determines its design.
And she was already talking about the fact that once digital information was
more prevalent,
it would come too fast and we'd need templates and ways to automate the,
the presentation of that material.
And this is a different idea than what existed working in a press and on,
on books.
She also made this film in order to show her students to get them to think about
the way that a grid plays out over time.
Okay.
Finally,
uh,
in 1979,
MIT press organized an exhibition called books 2000.
Looking forward to what books would be in the year of 2000.
And she was asked to put the bow house book in there and this is what she
offered,
which was the raw manuscript of the book and that stood in place.
Football coach,
I love it.
Kind of amazing.
Uh,
so just a stack of papers.
The original typewritten manuscript,
some of the other books that were passing through the press at the time include
a primer of visual literacy by Don,
say Dondis who we saw on this self portrait,
a Ascii art.
Um,
this is a graphic design textbook and his 33rd printing and other book is five
lender architecture,
which she did with Herbert Muschamp who became the architecture critic of the
New York Times.
This book was produced with a IBM Selectric typewriter to do the type setting
for it.
Um,
she published this book,
uh,
companion for Lydia illiterates by a Swiss designer and artists,
Carl Gerstner.
It was around,
um,
texts and typography as a kind of graphic event,
translated into English.
Now at the MIT press,
there were too many books as well to give much attention to every book.
And so a large part of what she did was think through the publishing and design
system that existed there.
And she developed pages and pages as far as we could.
Um,
Robert and I could discern,
uh,
and pages and pages of,
schemes for how books would pass through the press.
So here's a pretty legible one that begins with,
uh,
from easy to complicated,
from camera ready,
too difficult and they would engage different amounts of kind of design and
layout and uh,
editing production resources within the press.
And the result of that was that a rather high level of design across all the
books,
even books that were proceeding proceedings from a academic conferences like
this one 36 lectures at the biology would still have a strong high level of
design on them.
And this is what made the program says strong.
Uh,
here's a computer software manual.
Here's another software manual where we're computer,
where typewriter type is simply blown up to make the cover.
Um,
and finally,
here's a,
a last book I'm going to show.
It's not unimportant.
The subject matter of the books that were coming through the press cause she was
engaging with this material on reading it and this helped,
helped,
uh,
arrange her move into her next kind of phase within MIT
in 1974.
Muriel Cooper was,
was introduced to Ron Mcneil.
Ron was a photographic assistant at Mit.
Ron had a four color offset press,
which is a large printing press,
um,
about half the size of the stage I would guess.
And Ah,
there they immediately made a connection and thought it'd be amazing to teach a
class around this press where students were not only learning about design but
actually making the printed work and learning about how to run a printer and et
cetera.
Um,
they began teaching a class in the department of architecture at MIT called
messages and means this was the original poster which announced that class.
Um,
that class,
uh,
this poster was made in a,
using a method that she gave as an assignment often,
uh,
which was to use the same printing plate and overprint my rotating the,
the sheet of paper each time it goes through the press.
So you get kind of overlapping a rotated images on top of each other.
The press was also,
I mean the,
the,
that offset press presses also used to print posters for events that are
happening to MIT.
For example,
this,
uh,
which is the Macra,
the mechanical artwork,
the film actually for this poster which was announcing a traveling art
exhibition originating at,
uh,
MIT.
Here are a group of students gathered around the press and messages and means,
um,
I found this image some way into the kind of meandering research process and I
was really happy to see that asterisk poster up,
uh,
behind in the top left of this image.
Um,
uh,
which was a nice loop back to finding the real thing.
Originally,
uh,
the students were involved handed on printing.
I mean,
you can imagine this might be a maybe a liability nightmare and today's a
university,
but it was not at the time.
Um,
there is uh,
both a hands on,
there's a do it yourself ethic that was there was also manifested in the
assignments and the way that the students work.
They apparently kept all hours in this space and
as well what they're doing in there,
they're doing it self consciously.
So here,
this is Ron Mcneil and the center of this image and he's working with the offset
press and a cleaning it up or adjusting something.
And while he's doing that,
he's being recorded video recorded on a Sony Portapak video camera,
which would be brand new at this point.
It recorded in black and white.
It was handheld,
completely radical,
um,
image making technology.
And then all of this is being recorded by somebody with a,
with the camera at 35 millimeter camera from the other side.
So there's absolute,
although they were hands on making this,
they're also aware that what they're doing was interesting or worth the worth
thinking about.
Anyway,
worth representing
the messages.
Means class was,
was overwhelmingly popular.
And the next year a Mcneil and Cooper founded,
uh,
autonomous center within the school of Architecture called the visible language
workshop.
Uh,
it was centered around the printing press.
They offered a couple of additional classes and this became more what Muriel
Cooper was spending the bulk of her days doing.
This is a dummy for the letterhead for the visible language workshop.
Um,
what you see here is ears,
a printed version of it.
Uh,
what you see is a kind of ham fisted,
um,
a brush stroke but then which is filled in with the split fill,
split fountain printing process that Grady aids from,
from red to blue.
And it's a what?
It's something you can get to only do on the press.
That's why this mockup only shows that kind of working like this.
Um,
and again,
I think it's typical thinking designed through it's kind of production,
uh,
needs here.
Uh,
another version that letterhead,
uh,
that letter had as well reproduced well on a,
on a xerox machine and in fact they offered a class and visible language
workshop called electrostatics,
which was about xerox machines because this was a new image making technology.
It had the quality of making immediate prince,
you could work on it,
change your mind,
make another thing,
work on it.
And this kind of quick feedback loop was something she was always desiring of
the kind of graphic tools she was working with.
In 1980,
Muriel Cooper and Ron Mcneil were asked to submit an article for Department of
Architecture in House Journal called plan.
And the that was supposed to be about like what's going on in the visible
language workshop and instead of responding with the set of images or student
works or something like this,
a Cooper decided to um,
respond in different ways.
So this is actually the first page of the article and uh,
this was a letter back to the editor and the letter said,
um,
I'm going to read a little couple of excerpts from it.
She says,
we're not going to give you an image,
an article with a collection of images,
images of student work in,
uh,
instead,
the following are the article will fulfill the following criteria.
Number one,
it would make use of the tools,
processes,
and technologies of graphic arts media as directly as possible.
And tools would be integrated with concept and product.
Number two,
the author would be the maker contrary to the specialization mode,
which makes the author of the content,
the author,
the author of the form,
the designer,
and the author of the craft,
the topographer or printer number three,
visual and verbal representation.
And the idea would be synthesized rather than separate.
And number four,
this is the important one.
I think time would remain as fluid and immediate as possible.
Leaving room for feedback and change.
She signs off the letter and it kind of a beautiful turn of phrase.
She says,
well this stands as a sketch for the future and signs it.
Here's a spread from inside that article.
There's several spreads.
They were a black and white high contrast images just as described in that,
in that text they were made in the workshop.
Now on doing the research,
um,
I was really excited to come across this a page,
which is actually a mocked up,
a revised version of the letter that she eventually printed as the first page of
that article that are,
that letter was supposed to look off the cuff,
right?
But of course she worked at a,
and so here are her own corrections and notes on that.
And if you even get up to the top left,
you see it says a sketch if you will,
for the future.
Um,
and I think this document,
it's kind of markups and changes and feedback and different overlaps of a
printing and production technologies within it.
Um,
are uh,
kind of good way to read a lot of the intent in or other work.
Okay.
No visible language workshop was not just printing presses at the time.
Even from 1974 there is photographic,
there's a dark room and photographic equipment like a large format.
Xerox camera.
Um,
there was as well a Prodo Photoshop that Ron McNeil had developed with a
engineering students.
It was called sis and it allowed direct a pixel by Pixel manipulation of digital
images.
This is something completely radical at the time.
Uh,
here's Ron sitting in front of CIS,
a cis as well.
I had what they call it,
a scanner,
which is really a digital camera to get images into the system.
And it also included a large format inkjet printer,
which he called the billboard plotter,
which you see beyond him.
Um,
I think this image gives some idea of the kind of what it was like in the
workshop workshop was a series of three rooms,
a mix of analog and digital technologies and kind of no boundaries between these
things.
Lots of activity as far as I could understand,
but it was all towards an end of making a responsive,
uh,
iterative graphic tools for image making.
So here's a diagram,
perhaps notional,
uh,
the electronic equipment that was in the visible language workshop and the way
it,
the way it went together,
it included,
for example,
a $500,000,
uh,
Perkin Elmer computer,
um,
300 megabyte disk drive,
so on and so forth.
Now a Cooper made this image using a collection of that,
uh,
image making material.
Now this image was the two images that are of Muriel Cooper here.
W started out as video images made 1974 captured on Sony Porta pack.
Those images were digitized into and assists into that electronic,
a image manipulation software.
They were then 10 years later transmitted down the hall at Mit from one room to
another ever something on a slow scan.
Transmission was did they to a color facts,
same way they sent images from the moon and then finally those images were
displayed on a pair of stacked monitors and then that that whole contraption was
photographed with a 30 by 40 inch,
very large a Polaroid camera to give you this image where you see like the
chemical peel of the instant Polaroid.
You see the scan lines from the a CRT monitors,
you see Muriel Cooper wearing a Polaroid camera and SX 70 which would have been
brand new in 1974 around her neck and in fact it's even replacing one of her
eyes and the best,
the thing I liked the most about it is the fact that in one image she's making a
photograph of the person taking the video of her in the next image.
That image is out of her camera or getting ready to develop.
And if we could just,
just out of frame,
we'd see the person who was actually recording and which I never figured out who
we never figured out who it was.
In 1985,
Muriel Cooper was asked by Nicholas Negroponte,
um,
who was in the department of architecture and he was founding the media lab at
Mit and Muriel Cooper was invited as one of the founding faculty to establish,
um,
a research unit within it.
Now,
what I understand from the invitation was that,
uh,
she was asked to consider giving her group a new name,
not the visible language workshop.
She steadfastly refused.
She said,
you know,
it's even though we're going to be working on computer interfaces,
like it's the same.
It's the same concerns that I've been thinking about both at MIT press and with
the teaching.
It's all the same thing.
So she insisted on continuing the visible language workshop name.
Now,
the Mit Media Lab,
uh,
was as Negroponte described it.
Uh,
if the bow house was a design school for the industrial age and then the media
lab was to be a design school for the information age.
I'm here.
We see,
uh,
here's an inside of one of the rooms.
It was in a new building designed by I m Pei on the campus of Mit.
Um,
it,
uh,
consisted of a stacked floors of drop ceiling spaces with lots of CRT monitors
here and their carpet,
etc. Here's Muriel Cooper and Ron Mcneil in the space of the visible light of
the visible language workshop at the media lab.
Uh,
when they moved into the space,
they originally insisted that there would be heavy power in order to bring in
the printing presses,
but they got so interested in the,
um,
in the screens that they never brought in any of the analog printing material.
Some of the work they were doing,
their included reports such as this proposal called books without pages,
which imagines what it would mean to have a,
uh,
type on the screen essentially.
Um,
it includes um,
ideas about page flipping interfaces,
um,
dynamic text,
which communicates by the way that it changes over time.
They were working with a space at the media lab called the media room,
which was an immersive media environment all centered around an Eames lounger
chair and which included a projected wall size,
a interface,
a smaller touchscreen interface,
uh,
trackpads built into the um,
and built into the arms of the chair.
And uh,
the interfaces as well.
I had qualities that we,
when we can recognize now like skeuomorphic forms of the objects of these things
were meant to replicate.
I want to play a little bit,
this is a short clip of some of the research that was going on at,
at the visible language workshop at the time.
There are two very important things that the visible language workshop is,
is looking at.
One is the way in which graphics,
which we defined in the broadest sense can be used to filter,
define,
qualify and edit that information.
And secondly,
what the interface for the relationship at the surface or the access of the
person to the machine can be white to promote the most creative and the most
generative means of communication.
It's a major concern at the VFW is determining ways in which one can relate to
as a computer much in the same manner as you went to a friend or an assistant.
Uh,
in the short run.
What would be good to do is study ways in which rules can be modeled to the
machine.
So the machine will then begin to assume some of the responsibility for work,
which is repetitive or
describable.
We're working on a system which employees are rule based to assist in the
process of graphic design and texts layout to do this where using an expert
system development tool called CASS and we've chosen the design,
the business cards to serve as a case study.
The three of you worked professionally for national advertising or advertising,
the official
management.
What is your company's financial scale medium with the type of image would you
like to grow up gate progressive?
Please wait while I like at creative.
Given the internal rules that we've put into the system,
it's decided that this particular layout is appropriate for me based on the
answers I gave it.
Okay.
So it's funny,
yes.
But,
uh,
but even with some distance,
if you can erase the kind of a nostalgia and I mean,
just plain humor and it's in it,
uh,
you can see,
um,
an exploration of the desire of what we,
what we want those interfaces to do and how we want them to behave and how we
want them to relate to graphic design.
Even if these are paths kind of not taken in.
A lot of this work existed,
but it was,
it existed in tentative in a media formats which would fall away quickly,
which is a main motivation and kind of collecting this together both into a book
and into the exhibition and documenting the work at the media lab.
Goober did not write very often,
but she did edit one issue of design quarterly out of the Walker art center.
It was on computers and design and on the cover,
um,
she used a software program to do nine different versions of the cover,
which are reproduced on the cover.
They also were exploring what,
uh,
they called it the ultimate designer workstation and,
how we might use a screens and input devices,
uh,
to do graphic design and in an iterative,
responsive way.
Now this is an image that was,
this is an image from the vow also about the same time.
It's a large format,
Polaroid print,
kind of like that other one.
But this image started out in sis,
started out digital and never,
uh,
and remained digital.
Uh,
and I,
it was,
um,
what I liked so much about,
there's a great insight that Muriel Cooper had.
Do you think maybe one of her strongest,
which early on this is a late 1970,
she said,
well,
in time,
uh,
digital images are gonna stay on the screen and they're going to have a life of
their own through networks.
I mean,
it sounds like,
uh,
I mean,
of course we know that,
right?
But at the time we did not know that.
And the way in which she pushed that through and made,
uh,
this image for example,
to kind of stand as a pointer towards that idea.
I'm just nearly done.
We're going to watch the last thing,
which is,
uh,
Muriel Cooper introducing that Ted talk where we started.
And,
uh,
we'll let the video that she showed,
let that play and we'll
move on
and design of the Haitian like B.
And then for many years we've been building for the prototype and visualization.
Ooh.
That would allow us to do something that seemed relatively
intuitive and in order to say,
what if we did this,
then what would happen?
But to really visualize this stuff in as tight an iterative loop it and as the
class that we could,
so we're looking for the design principle.
Um,
we're not at all sure what they are.
Then she proceeded to show this,
uh,
this work,
which is called the information landscapes.
And it was a proposal for an immersive typographic and environment.
The user navigates their way through that uses,
uh,
relationships,
three dimension over relationships in space to articulate,
uh,
relationships.
That might be a communicated on a two dimensional surface by bold and Roman or
type size or other kinds of typographic relationships.
And so this,
uh,
this interface in a lot of ways collected her ideas about,
the user and the reader having some degree of agency and the design and
orientation,
the materials that they're using.
It,
uh,
it leveraged off of a traditional graphic design knowledge but then rethought it
in a completely new manner.
As I described this work,
I had a large impact when it was shown and she traveled around showing it
elsewhere.
Um,
this was in 1994 and in February,
1994,
she returned back to Cambridge after a trip to England and,
uh,
died unexpectedly of a heart attack.
Um,
the,
the work in the meantime,
um,
I feel like hasn't been replicated or communicated or dealt with to the degree
that I thought it would.
Um,
and I think it's an open question as to why that's the case.
Certainly had the,
uh,
when she died was,
um,
must be part of it,
but it must be part of a larger story about how it's difficult to file the work
under existing categories.
That's one thing,
uh,
what a design practice might look like.
That's,
um,
that's made with other people and that it doesn't sit in neatly defined
disciplinary boundaries.
[inaudible]
thanks David.
That was great.
I want to just start this off.
I'm looking at this image because this was my way into Muriel Cooper.
I saw the photo before I knew of her or had seen her work and was immediately
drawn to it for all of the reasons that you had previously said.
She is barefoot.
She's surrounded by unidentified men as you put it.
Um,
so I wanted to ask you how you came to Mariel's work.
what was your way in
my way into her work was twofold.
I originally,
I was,
when I first start working in graphic design,
I was working at Ideo in San Francisco from 1995,
1997.
I was working for a media lab student named Geeta Solomon,
who was head of interaction design there.
And I was hired as an interaction designer and I didn't even even quite know
what that meant.
I was barely a graphic designer at that point.
Um,
and uh,
however at ideo there was a hotbed of activity around that emerging field and a
lot of it's centered around Muriel Cooper's work,
either people who had gone to the media lab or people who knew it,
et cetera.
So that,
that's,
um,
that's when I was originally introduced to it.
And then I came back to it when in 2006,
I think 2005,
2006,
uh,
when I was working doing graphic design for the Mit Center for advanced visual
studies.
And that was,
uh,
I went up there and found a closet full of posters that had a inventory.
Oh,
kind of listing of what all the things they had done at the place over the
years.
And they were exceptional posters.
And I thought,
oh,
these must have been designed by Muriel Cooper because I knew she was around and
etc. And so that piqued my interest and I started to look into it.
It turns out none of them were designed by Muriel Cooper,
but she'd printed most of them.
So again,
it's kind of like the sideways,
um,
and anybody that that drew me into the work.
And that became a fellowship with MIT and then,
uh,
led to a small,
original text.
And then to then with Robert Reason Burger,
it turned into an exhibition.
And then with rob as well,
the book long version.
I also wanted to ask you about the books epigraph,
which is a quote from Muriel Cooper a that says,
I guess I'm never sure that print is truly linear.
And that's a quote that she gave Jen,
Janet Abrams in that ID story.
Um,
what's the significance of this quote for you and Robert?
why did you choose to start the book that way?
Uh,
I'm pretty sure it was rob who thought of it as the epigraph in the book and I,
I said,
that's fantastic.
But why,
why it was appealing was it has the circular quality of the way that she speaks
and thinks.
And so it's like she says,
uh,
she admits to doubt in the statement,
you know,
it's not like she says,
books are not truly linear.
Print is not truly linear.
She says,
I'm not,
I'm not convinced.
Right.
And so,
uh,
it's that kind of productive doubt that runs through our work and it sounds like
typical of how she would speak and seems like a great way to,
uh,
slight a lightly perverse way to start a giant Hardebeck monograph.
Hmm.
I like that.
I think that right before that quote in that interview too,
she,
she had,
she was reversing something that she said,
right.
She said it was linear and then she goes back and says,
um,
I'm never quite sure.
So I see that.
Go ahead.
Circle of doubt.
Um,
so you frame your essay in the book around seven artifacts,
um,
and you zero in on those pieces to tell a particular story about Mario's work as
a whole.
Um,
I'm wondering if,
um,
outside of those seven pieces that you feature in the book,
are there any that just didn't make the cut?
Any edge cases that we should know about?
There are so many,
there are,
there are so many.
MMM.
There are so many that just didn't fit because of space and that's it.
Um,
the work that's in the archive probably as of quite uneven quality and so
sometimes they were picked for the subject matter as much as for the kind of
graphic design or whatever interest in them.
Um,
I'd say we scratched the surface.
Uh,
her work was exceedingly well documented in terms of collected.
Um,
it wasn't organized at the time,
although Massachusetts College of art where the Muriel Cooper archive is,
has done incredible work to put it together and then they were very generous
with us giving us access and pulling things and reproducing things.
And,
great.
Um,
and then last question and then I'll open it up to you guys to ask some
questions and the,
the mix over to the side.
Um,
can you talk about the influence that Muriel Cooper's work has had on your own
work?
Okay.
Um,
I think as I was,
as I was describing in the talk,
she was always interested in,
uh,
both doing the work and being aware of doing the work or kind of interrogating
what it is to do the work.
And I think that's something that I've borrowed quite a lot from,
from her model and,
um,
which is a degree of kind of reflexivity in the,
in like doing design and how it gets done.
And,
uh,
this is not for the sake of a introspection or anything like this,
but rather it's to productively kind of question assumptions that exist.
And so,
um,
uh,
so that's certainly one way that she's influenced me.
And I think the second way,
the second kind of direct influence,
uh,
she had is,
um,
is just through,
I'm imagining a interfaces that were completely real time and that,
uh,
that kind of evolved with the,
with the point of view of the person using it.
And that's something that we know well now,
but didn't know well even when I started working.
Great.
All right.
Anybody else have questions for David?
I just wanted to,
after her death,
what happened to the visible language,
the poetry,
where there people,
you could actually continue her work.
What did it really stop with her death?
There were people,
there were her students,
Ron Mcneil is still living.
That was her partner in the visible language workshop.
Um,
there were all of her students continued and a left and kind of create this
diaspora of Tlw work.
Um,
for example,
Lisa Strauss valid was there at the time.
She's gone on to do lots of things within graphic design proper.
Um,
uh,
the,
there are students who didn't directly study under her but studied after her in
what became the physical language workshop under John Mayeda.
Like Ben Frye has gone on to do lots of work.
Um,
so it continued,
but it continued,
uh,
a would they kind of sudden,
whoa.
So I think that a change things,
I was just looking at the work again in sort of realizing how radical it's still
looks to today.
How unexpected.
Um,
and I just wanted to know,
I mean,
often when the future gets here,
it arrives in kind of a normal way or an expected way.
And I just,
what do you think about radical interfaces now?
Um,
I wonder if it's a,
I wonder if it's partly a factor of her working in an academic context.
You know,
I think,
I think yes to work does look radical.
It didn't look like anything else that existed when it and when it emerged.
Um,
and I think,
uh,
I think that is partly to do with her kind of finding a unique line through
graphic design and interface design that other people weren't following.
I mean,
I understand that she would always watch cartoons on Saturday mornings because
that kind of animation was interesting to her for her work.
I didn't know what,
not that it looked like that,
but the,
all the techniques,
how you abstract out and use graphics to filter information and,
you know,
play things out dynamically every time.
So it's like,
you know,
she might've said that was a radical interface.
Um,
I have no idea about radic radical interfaces now other than,
um,
of course in a commercial situation,
it's,
it's a more challenging to,
um,
to introduce something that doesn't have a precedent because it,
uh,
it relies on all the conventions that they exist.
So the radical things have to be radical in one way and not radical at all and
in another way.
Right.
I'm just curious for your thoughts,
given that so many of the people who came after him,
Muriel Cooper,
uh,
they are interaction designers,
they sometimes self identify as artists.
What do you think is her ultimate legacy?
Is there a way to tidally tie that up given that we're in a room full of Ux
designers today?
Yeah,
I think our presence is most felt within graphic design is it kind of transfers
over to interaction design.
Um,
so,
um,
so I suppose,
and so I don't think her legacy is a visible at all.
And Art,
let's say,
even if some of the people who she influenced kind of win on in that are
identified in that direction.
Um,
I think her background and training was graphic design.
So that's where the or the work is kind of legible.
So I think probably her legacy exists in a lots of graphic designers today.
I'll make you know,
most graphic designers today who are working uh,
on screen as the,
as the destination.
So it's a disburse legacy.
I don't know,
it's not a,
it's certainly not easy to identify it concretely,
but they're,
they're concrete parts to it.
Like,
um,
for example,
the architecture machine group at the beginning of the 1970s,
they were developing anti les type is every time we see type on the screen
that's blurred in order to make it sharper.
That came from there or interfaces that use kind of immediate feedback to
acknowledge a kind of user input and that that gap between when the action
happens and its corresponding effect on screen was a reduced,
reduced is directly comes from our work.
So
I'm actually curious to know,
maybe these are two questions,
but they're actually one,
I'm curious to know what the graphic design community thought of Miro Cooper.
Um,
I mean graphic design until very recently seems to be still a little bit fearful
of computers.
I mean,
coding isn't even taught in most graphic design programs.
Um,
I recall reading a little bit of Paul ran and him being sort of very,
very skeptical of what computers could do in the early design process.
And I wonder how mural communicated the value of computers or new interfaces in
the more pure graphic design world.
I mean,
I'm sure she felt right in at MIT media lab,
but how about outside of that?
Yeah.
You know,
I think,
um,
well she never learned how to program.
She tried a bunch of times and kind of,
it never,
it was not something that she was a,
wanted to spend enough time to engage with even though,
and she was consistently frustrated apparently by how slow computers,
where no matter what,
no matter what newest computer is always like,
you know,
she was cursing up a storm saying,
uh,
saying this is too slow.
So I also understand that she would like insist on breaking out conversations of
design from technology,
which sounds funny in retrograde,
but,
uh,
at least at Strauss failed has mentioned that that was,
that was an eyeopening distinction for her because you could talk about the way
something worked and felt and what it should do in absence of what it can do or
cannot do.
So,
uh,
I think by making,
probably by making that distinction that helped her have a clearer foothold in
the graphic design community.
But I also think her work is necessarily messy.
It's not like tidy graphic design.
And so she was embraced.
But,
um,
but I,
I expect there's good bit of skepticism as well within that community also.
Okay.
It looks like we're at a time.
I think so.
Thanks,
David.
Thank you.
[inaudible].